was on I was online uh yesterday and I
I've been online yeah the World Wide Web
have yeah yeah it's crazy yeah and my
friend Bobby Lee got hacked I was with
him I know put it up Jen he's gotta just
it had to be from porn
but how do you get her explain explain
this to me everybody my Twitter got
hacked so um Elon I texted that Lex
Friedman respond I need help you know um
and whoever the fool who did the Twitter
help me out now laughs
it's a loving Embrace between two people
who sure yeah if you notice right at the
end of it yeah like it I think are you
doing a bit because right at the end
right at the end you stayed too long and
you can hear him he goes okay okay yeah
you have to like re-edit that to get rid
of the case
your forearm is resting comfortably on
his penis yeah yeah it's a small yet uh
welcoming area you saw that and you said
you wanted to recreate that today uh no
no no but yeah
on his chest but why are two of you why
are you so for those who are just
listening this was a uh post this is a
Bobby Lee post you'd been hacked his
Twitter got hacked he didn't know what
to do and his friends like make a post
on Instagram let everybody know don't
send me money if I ask for money okay
but see sitting on a couch in his
underpants Bobby and I go back to the
dark days of the car Comedy Store you
were in your underpants too constantly
doing yeah we're like we're like oh
let's make a video or both like Get
Naked like yeah get naked and then he
goes oh hold on hold on underwear on
oh wait there was a version before dude
Bobby is in a is in such an in-between
State between the industry like like you
say like you want to honor Crest is
giving you money for to to say open that
[ __ ] briefcase you know right so
don't be a complete animal right Bobby's
one foot in there and one foot in the
Animal World
um and I I went to his podcast once a
long time ago and I brought some candy
bars and I put them in the freezer when
I got there we were talking for a while
and he was like you know I can't do
certain things I'm on an ABC show and I
was like but Bobby I know who you are
you're a comedy store animal and he's
like what are the candy bars for Ari and
I'm like you know what the candy bars
are for Bob and he goes no we're not
doing that I'm like Bobby I know who you
are he goes I'm on ABC Ari and I'm like
you're gonna put these candy bars up
your butt he goes no I can't I'm on
American Broadcasting Company and I'm
like Bobby you are a comedy store comic
and he goes fine I'll put him on my butt
but I got to do it right in your face
and I'm like all right well played
that's going to hurt me and he spread
his cheeks and we put Twix bars up his
butt no you did not yeah yeah
it's on YouTube somewhere yeah yeah is
it really yeah look at that what would
it be under uh re shoves to expires up
he shoved it himself I was just he just
you were just there but you you actually
you went to us
and I brought us Snickers to see how
much you'd want to go for it so you put
those first the snippers or that is this
it yeah wait I want to see what
sometimes the old days can you do me a
favor can you go uh to the fridge into
the freezer and get the candy bars I had
in there
I put some candy bars
I'm sorry
I don't even work here we're putting
candy bars up your [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's a photo yeah
not filled this before podcast
first of all I'm on an ABC show now yeah
you are man
yeah you're gonna put candy bars in your
butt so you had seen him do this
house one day and I'm like yeah
okay okay I don't know which one I
couldn't realize who he is okay
I swore to God I'm not sticking [ __ ]
candy bars yeah you are now why would
you do this because that's who you are
Bobby this is who you are I have a
friend this is who you are
you're not hateful anymore
how about this oh you know what I will
stick it in my butt you know all right
great I can edit oh
lonely
you want to smell it oh my God
if you stick it in I'll smell it smell
it
this is the most disgusting thing I've
ever seen in my life
oh my gosh those are chocolate it don't
smell like chocolate
all right all right all right all right
enough enough
Jen turn it on look at the face oh my
gosh
are you kidding me
oh my God
[Music]